if you can pull up this one clip just
play this clip and go to I don't know
play uh go to 45 seconds yeah about a
minute or so go to a minute and press
play I see an opportunity to make money
I go with I'm happy make them feel more
confident
listen to what this guy says 12 years
ago um
personally uh it doesn't matter that's
it see I'm a Trader uh I don't really
care about that kind of stuff I go with
what the I if I see an opportunity to
make money I go with that
um so for most Traders it's not about is
that we don't really care that much how
they're going to fix the how they're
going to fix the economy how they're
going to fix the uh the whole situation
our job is to make money from it and
personally I've been dreaming of this
one for three years I I had a confession
which is I go to bed every night I dream
of another recession I dream of another
Moment Like This why because people
don't seem to maybe remember but the 30s
depression the depression 1930s wasn't
just about a market crash there were
some people who were prepared to make
money from that that's the part and
that's something anybody should talk
about it isn't just for some people in
the elite listen to the ladies anybody
who can actually make money it's an
opportunity uh when the market crashes
uh when the Euro and the big stock must
crash if you know what to do
um
if you have the right plan to set up you
can you can make a lot of money from
this for example
hedging strategies is one
um
investing in bonds treasury bonds that
sort of stuff see the people around me
jaws have collectively dropped at what
you've just said I mean we appreciate
your candor however it doesn't help the
rest of us does it all the rest of the
Euro Zone listen I would say this to
everybody who's watching this
this economic crisis is like a cancer if
you just wait and wait thinking this is
going to go away just like a cancer is
going to grow and it's gonna be too late
what I would say to everybody is get
prepared
uh there's another time right now to
um wishful thinking the government is
going to sort things out the governments
don't rule the world Goldman Sachs rules
the world wow
so so what do you take from that message
just as as a person maybe you're not in
finance when you hear that how do you
process what he just said says I dream
about a recession happens every 10 years
in the 30s a lot of wealth was created
government doesn't run everything
Goldman it's up to you when [ __ ] hits
the fan it's up to you to to take it and
Adam's been saying this forever it's an
opportunity it's I mean it's not a
really good looking opportunity but you
have to jump on and be ready like right
now just just from hearing that in my
head I'm like I have to ask both of you
after this What bond should I be looking
at and what you know Goldman Sachs what
the hell are they up to because just be
ready just be prepared because like
right now I mean Pat do you guys think
it's going to be I mean it's the White
House is you know they beat us every
single day everything's fine borders
fine economy is great everything's fine
when I I know we talked about it 13
months you said so now we're getting to
like the six or seven more months so
everything goes kaputs you think we're
still going towards that so just look at
it this way this is this is what I said
the other day okay
and if you go to Dow Jones history of
Dow Jones just go to history Dow Jones
this is all you need to know okay just
type in doubt yeah history of Dow Jones
hide you know uh oh let me see if you
can pull this up or not if you can go
Max how many years back does it go to uh
82. okay what was it at 82 907. okay
what is it in 1990 go to 1990. it's
2600. okay what's that two thousand
uh Ten rounds okay what's that 2010.
um 10 grand okay what's that 2020.
so here's the point guy and what was it
at 1980 go all the way back to what it
was 27 I think 907 907 guys so meaning
it went from 907 to 10 grand to 20 grand
to 30 grand the Dow in the next 40 years
so if it was at 40 so if we take 907
into 30 what's 907 into 30. roughly 35
times okay 33 times right 35 times
so that means if we take 30 000 down
today okay thirty thousand thirty
thousand down today and we do times 35
is what that means that will be at a
million in 42 years
so meaning long term you're gonna be
fine long term Innovation is going to be
fine but for people that are sitting
there saying I truly want to create
wealth you have to if you have some
savings right now you did it right
you're going to be able to capitalize
because a lot of things are going to be
on sale you're going to buy a condo a
house on nothing in my opinion in the
next 12 months the level of discounted
properties is going to be insane in 12
months like discount in a way that you
never thought you'd be paying that kind
of a discount on 12 months but you have
to also be thinking about this is if
you're if you're 30 years old this is
probably going to happen only five times
in your lifetime wow if you're 40 years
old it's probably only going to happen
four times in your lifetime if you're 20
years old six times wow you have to be
ready for your the next one that's gonna
happen in 10 years and the way you do
that is by piling up a bunch of cash and
you make some good Investments and 10
years from now you ready when it happens
again because we're gonna go through the
cyclical cycle so my my uh uh uh my uh
prediction is the following who gave
birth to Ronald Reagan
Jimmy Carter okay who's the closest
president to Jimmy Carter Joseph Biden
Joseph Biden and how long was Jimmy how
long was Ronald Reagan president eight
years who became the next president his
VP senior so Republican state for 12
years then what happened after 12 years
Clinton showed up that's eight years
what happened after Clinton GW what
happened after him Obama what happened
you know half terms is going to be one
one term there's going to be 2-1
tournaments so we haven't had a 1-1
tournament in a long time wow you get
what I'm saying it's going to be a
one-one turn assuming Biden is not the
best
well you'll see the numbers that we're
looking at so the point is this this
economy the way it's going this is going
to give birth to a conservative
president for the next eight years
whether it's going to be a DeSantis
whether it's going to be a trump if it's
a DeSantis and it follows Carter's
Playbook whoever DeSantis chooses as VP
could most likely end up being the next
president as well so if the census pick
pick a name I don't know just give me
any name Nikki Haley yeah okay give me
any name it's not going to be Nikita but
let's just say it's going to be Nikki
Haley sorry 12 years now so that's 12
years okay then the Market's gonna sit
there and say whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa a
little too much yeah Richard getting too
rich this is not fair you have too many
trillionaires why should Elon Musk be a
trillionaire then it's gonna flip but
all I'm saying is during this time folks
here's all I'm saying Andy Grove I'm
gonna keep saying this as many times as
possible who ran a company called Intel
that grew a hundred percent rate that
everybody in Silicon Valley swore by
this Hungarian guy that built one of the
best stories in Silicon Valley he wrote
a book and the book was called only the
paranoid survive simple as that and too
many people are not paranoid today I'm
gonna do great people are good only the
paranoid survive so you need a little
bit of that mindset of only the
paranoids survive today because if you
don't in a market tanks because here's
what happens if Dave Ramsey is right
guess what nothing changes great he's
right but if Dave Ramsey is wrong a lot
of people who listen to him are screwed
because they sat there saying the market
is not going to crash he didn't prepare
them to say it could potentially happen
so if you like this clip and you want to
watch another one click right here and
if you want to watch the entire podcast
click right here
foreign
[Music]